one misconception of meditation is that
if you're meditating your mind will be
blank you can't make your mind blank
and if you try you're just going to wind
up with a gigantic headache
in a way when we're on autopilot we're
sleepwalking through our lives
mindfulness is traditionally a form
of meditation it's the awareness that
arises
from paying attention on purpose in the
present moment
and non-judgmentally if you're breathing
this class could be for you
i've been committed to mindfulness for
well over
50 years it's a way in which you could
take care of your body
take care of your mind and that's what
this is really about
the entire thrust of this masterclass
is not about attaining it's about
recognizing you're already whole
when you set about bringing mindfulness
into your life
the best coping strategy is to recognize
stress and how to minimize our
reactivity to those stressors no matter
how stressful no matter how painful i
could ground myself
in the present moment stop remember
we can cultivate mindfulness in an array
of different ways
and the beauty of meditation is some
forms will resonate with some people
and other forms will resonate
differently with other people
i do not consider this to be a master
class this is not about
mastery i'm not the curriculum you're
the curriculum
this is an invitation to befriend
yourself
and sign up for the adventure of a
lifetime this is john kevitzen
and this is my non-master class
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you